hello and welcome to another gamespot  news update i'm kate and today's news  story is about a man whose life was  saved by playing video games a man was  hit by a car while playing fallout 4 in  his home last Sunday he survived with  injuries and attributes his survival to  being a gamer CBS reported that Ben rose  was traveling through fallout 4s  Bostonian wasteland when a Hyundai  Sonata came crashing through the wall of  his home the accident fractured his  vertebrae and sliced his Achilles tendon  you play in a way son and then your  apartment turns into a wasteland said  Rose cars versus people don't really end  up well so I really thought it was over  he credited his special rolling gaming  chair with saving his life the chair is  what saved me without that that took the  impact